The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: We're now on
storyboard 12, session 13.
Let's take a look
first at panel A.
I mentioned earlier
that respiration
is the oxidative metabolism
of all metabolic fuels,
carbohydrates as well as lipids.
If we were starting
with a carbohydrate then
respiration starts with the
pyruvate dehydrogenase reaction
and then proceeds
into the TCA cycle,
and then into electron transport
and oxidative phosphorylation.
If the acetylcholine comes from
fatty acid oxidation, which
we'll cover later,
then we do not
have to do the pyruvate
dehydrogenase step.
Three molecules of NADH
and one molecule of FADH2
are produced as the
carriers of electrons
from the intermediates
in the TCA cycle
from each input molecule
of acetyl coenzyme A.
As I mentioned a
number of times,
we look at NADH and FADH2 as
relatively mobile electron
carriers.
They're going to be
picking up electrons
from intermediates and
biochemical pathways
and then they bring
those electrons
into the mitochondrial
inner membrane, where
the reducing equivalents are
passed along to the electron
transport chain.
Ultimately the
electrons will end up
being deposited into
oxygen to make water.
Let's turn to panel B
where I'm going to start
laying out the big picture.
In this small cartoon
we see fuel being
oxidized to carbon dioxide.
The electrons are passed
to either in NAD-plus,
or FAD to form the
reduced cofactor.
The reduced co-factors
find their way
to the mitochondrial
inner membrane
and the electrons, or
reducing equivalents,
are passed to oxygen
to make water.
This process is
highly exergonic.
And we'll do a model
calculation in a minute
to show just how
energy yielding it is,
resulting in the liberation
of a lot of free energy.
That energy is captured
by the movement of protons
from one side of the
mitochondrial inner membrane
to the other side
of the membrane.
In this process you're taking
a low concentration of protons
and creating a relatively
high concentration of protons.
That's an uphill process that's
going to require an energy
input, and the energy
from nutrient oxidation
is what powers this
generation of an ion gradient.
Concentrating the protons
in a small defined space
is kind of like
charging a battery.
It took energy to create that
high concentration of protons.
We'll see that nature invented a
way to channel the protons back
through a device and a way to
capture the energy released
when the gradient is dissipated.
That energy can be
captured in various ways,
enabling us to be able to
do useful things with it.
For example, the
energy could be used
to accomplish the otherwise
energy requiring process
of putting a phosphate
onto ADP to make ATP,
and that way the energy is
captured in a chemical bond.
Alternatively, let's think
of a situation in which
you may need to generate heat.
You could allow
the protons simply
to flow back across the
membrane through a channel.
The energy of the
proton gradient
would then be released as heat.
Thirdly, we can perhaps allow
the protons to flow back
through a device that
creates rotary movement
and that's how, for
example, a flagellar
motor can spin to move
a bacterium from one
place to another.
Let's now turn to
panel C. We've seen
earlier that
oxidation can result
in the production
of NADH or FADH2.
To begin let's consider NADH.
In this panel you can
see the NADH oxidized
where the electrons
flow-- and it
doesn't matter what
the path of the flow
is-- all the way to
oxygen. Thermodynamics
gives us the tools to
calculate how much energy you
would get in this process.
JoAnne taught you a lot
about thermodynamics
in biological systems,
And this is just
a repeat of what she said.
But what I'm going
to do is put what
she said into a concrete,
practical example.
I've drawn out at
the bottom of panel C
the overall reaction, showing
electrons going from NADH
to oxygen in the
forward direction.
Now, of course, we could also
think about the back reaction,
where electrons would flow
from water into NAD-plus
to form NADH.
At this point this is just an
equation on a piece of paper
and we don't know
in which direction
the reaction is
overall favorable.
That is, is it favorable
in the forward direction
as drawn, left to right, or
in the reverse direction,
right to left?
The reaction from left
to right is the direction
we usually think about in the
context of nutrient oxidation.
Interestingly, the
reaction from right to left
is photosynthesis.
So both directions
are biologically used,
but we'll see that
one of the directions
will require substantial
energy input in order
to make it biologically useful.
Probably you can appreciate
that photosynthesis
is the energy requiring
process, because we all
know that sunlight
is needed to make
the process thermodynamically
and kinetically favorable.
We don't cover photosynthesis
in 5.07, so let
me say a few words about it.
In photosynthesis nature
takes electrons from water
and uses them to reduce
NADP-plus to NADPH.
Note that I said NADP-plus,
and not NAD-plus,
but for the purposes
here they are equivalent.
In the case of photosynthesis
we know intuitively
that the overall process
is powered by light,
so in going from right to
left the process intuitively,
once again, should
require energy.
By contrast, nutrient
oxidation, where
we go from left to
right in this equation,
should be a process
that generates energy.
But intuition aside,
let's do the calculation.
So the question is,
in which direction
is the equation at the bottom
of panel C thermodynamically
favorable-- left to
right or right to left?
Let's take a look
now at panel D.
You'll see here that I
have split the master
equation into half reactions.
I always write out
the half reaction
in the direction of reduction.
For example, look at the
second half reaction.
It shows that half
a mole of oxygen
plus two protons, plus two
electrons, go to water.
Again, I've written
out these reactions
in the direction of reduction.
It's just the way I do it.
Next I go to the
redox chart, that
is the table of redox potentials
of electrochemical reactions,
and I figure out what the
standard energies are for each
of these half reactions.
As you can see, it's 0.32
volts, and, plus 0.82 volts
respectively, for the
two half reactions.
Next I use a variant
of the Nernst equation
to calculate the free
energy and ultimately
the directionality
of the reaction.
The equation I use is
delta G naught prime equals
N times Faraday's constant,
times the difference
in the reduction potentials
of the two half reactions.
To find delta E
naught prime, we look
at the reaction that
I've written out,
the overall reaction,
and we looked
at see which is the
electron acceptor,
in which is the
electron donor the way
the reaction was written.
Then we subtract the
reduction potential
of the electron receptor from
that of the electron donor.
The way the equation is
written, left to right, oxygen
is the electron acceptor.
It's reduction potential is plus
0.82 volts, so delta E naught
prime is plus 0.8 to
minus a minus 0.32,
or a total of plus 1.14 volts.
In the Nernst
equation, the number
of electrons transferred
in this case is two,
and Faraday's constant
is 96.4 kilojoules
per mole times volts.
If you do the math,
or as we say at MIT,
plug and chug, what
you find out is
that the free energy change of
the reaction that's written,
the NADH oxidation reaction, is
minus 220 kilojoules per mole.
This number is negative and that
means the reaction is favorable
as drawn.
That is, the reaction
goes from left to right.
The 220 kilojoules is
the amount of energy
that's available for the
three purposes of the pathway.
That is, ATP synthesis, heat
generation, or movement.
If we were going to make ATP,
we would divide 220 by 32,
because we get about
32 kilojoules of energy
by hydrolysis of ATP,
and we can calculate
that we're going
to get something
in the order of about 3
ATPs for every NADH that
gives up two electrons to
the electron transport chain.
We could easily do the same
oxidation reaction and study
FADH2, but in this
case, we would calculate
that we would get actually less
energy, because the oxidation
potential of flavins, as
compared to NAD, is different.
In that case, that
is, FADH2 oxidation,
you would get only about
two ATPs per FADH2 oxidized.
So the FADH2 produced in
the succinate dehydrogenase
step of the TCA
cycle is less energy
yielding than, for example,
the oxidation of malate
to oxaloacetate that occurs
later in the pathway.
Let's turn now to storyboard 13.
We now have an idea of
the rough amount of energy
that's going to be generated
by nutrient oxidation.
Next we're going to
look a little bit more
in detail at the mechanism
by which the electrons are
transported from the
reduced substances
that constitute our electron
donors, NADH and FADH2,
to molecular oxygen, or
whatever the terminal electron
acceptor is in the biological
system under study.
As was seen, the
electron transfer
process that we've been
studying liberates energy,
and that energy is going to
be used to power pumps that
will transport protons from
the matrix of the mitochondrian
out into the intermembrane space
between the mitochondrial inner
and outer membranes.
In the case of
electron transport
with the goal of ATP
synthesis, the protons
that are generated in
the intermembrane space
will be allowed to flow
back through a device
that mechanically
couples motion--
that is the spinning
of a shaft--
to drive conformational
changes in enzymes
that will allow the otherwise
endergonic synthesis of ATP
from ADP in inorganic phosphate.
That machine is called
the ATP synthase.
Let's look at
panel A. This panel
shows the details of the
electron transport system.
It looks a little
bit complicated,
but let's not lose sight of the
fact that what it's all about
is powering pumps,
pumps that pump protons.
In the lower left
of the panel we
see the TCA cycle
generating NADH and FADH2.
The NADH approaches complex
one of the mitochondrial inner
membrane.
Complex one is in an NADH
dehydrogenase enzyme.
The enzyme has a flavin
that accepts the electrons
from NADH, passes them along
to iron sulfur centers,
and then to a variety
of cytochromes.
It moves the electrons up
to the point where they're
going to be
transferred to coenzyme
Q. In its oxidized
form, coenzyme Q
binds to complex one.
The oxidized form
of coenzyme Q will
be reduced first
to a semiquinone
and then to a hydroquinone,
which are located, as shown,
inside the mitochondrial
inner membrane.
We usually draw them
as being free floating
within the membrane, but
that's probably inaccurate.
These co-factors
are probably bound
to physical entities inside the
mitochondrial inner membrane.
The picture also shows FADH2
from the TCA cycle interacting
with complex two, which is
a flavin containing enzyme,
and it will also
transfer its electrons
to the oxidized
form of coenzyme Q,
ultimately to create
the reduced coenzyme
QH2 which is the hydroquinone.
Just as a point of
reference to the TCA cycle,
complex two is also known
as succinate dehydrogenase.
We haven't done fatty
acid oxidation yet,
but there's a step in
fatty acid oxidation
in which an alkane is
converted to an alkene.
The electrons from
that oxidation reaction
go through a flavin
protein called ETF-pre,
for electron transferring
flavor protein, and once again
those electrons
flow into coenzyme Q
to form the reduced
form of coenzyme Q.
Remember when we talked about
the glycerol three phosphate
shuttle?
I mentioned that there's
a mitochondrial membrane
associated glycerol three
phosphate dehydrogenase.
You can see that enzyme at the
top part of the inner membrane
as I've drawn it.
And once again,
flavin in that enzyme
will carry the electrons
into coenzyme Q,
generating reduced form
of the co-factor QH2.
The left part of this
picture pretty neatly
shows how nutrient oxidation
can channel the electrons
into a common mobile
electron carrier,
coenzyme Q. Lots
of different fuels
give up their electrons to
a common electron carrier.
The hydroquinone QH2
will then go and interact
with complex three of the
electron transport chain.
In complex three, electrons
will be transported
through a number of different
electron relay stations
and ultimately be picked
up by cytochrome C, which
is initially in its plus
three oxidation state.
Cytochrome C is reduced
by the single electron
coming through complex three.
In this process its iron is
reduced to its plus two state.
This electron on
cytochrome C then
migrates across
the outer surface
of the inner membrane
of the mitochondrian
to interact with complex four.
When it interacts
with complex four,
the reduced form cytochrome
C gives up its electron
to a copper residue
on the copper
A subunit of complex four.
In the figure, this
complex is called CuA.
the more common name for complex
four is cytochrome C oxidase.
So cytochrome c oxidase
oxidizes is the iron back
to its iron three oxidation
state, then cytochrome C
migrates back to
complex three where
it's able to pick
up another electron.
We can think of cytochrome C as
a mobile electron carrier that
shuttles an electron
along the inner surface
of the mitochondrial
inner membrane.
Looking back at complex four,
or cytochrome C oxidase,
the electrons are
passed from cytochrome A
to a series of other
electron carriers,
and ultimately they flow
into molecular oxygen.
Molecular oxygen is anchored
on one side to heme A3
and on the other
side to copper B.
Oxygen undergoes a four
electron reduction and picks
up four protons along the way
to form two molecules of water.
If the electrons started with
NADH and ends up in oxygen
to form water, you get
220 kilojoules of energy.
And as I said, you
get somewhat less
of your electrons started
out as a reduced flavin.
Now let's look at
panel B. I want
to say a few words at the
outset about proton pumps,
keeping in mind that the
reason electrons were moved
through the electron transport
chain was to power these pumps.
In the lower left part of the
figure, we can see complex one.
The transit of electrons
through complex one from NADH
results in the transport
of four protons
from the mitochondrial matrix
into the intermembrane space.
That is, two electrons
from NADH are transported,
and coincident with
that, four protons
are pumped into the
intermembrane space.
Later we'll see
that complex three
is the location of something
called the Q cycle.
I'm going to cover
the proton pumping
properties of the Q
cycle in some detail
in the next storyboard.
The passage of
those two electrons
through complex three
results in the transport
of an additional four protons
into the intermembrane space.
Lastly, the transit of
electrons through complex four,
the cytochrome C
oxidase, results
in the transport of
another two protons
into the intermembrane space.
Now let's look at panel
C. Adding things up,
if we start with
two electrons coming
from NADH we transport
about 10 protons
into the intermembrane space.
That's enough to make about
three molecules of ATP.
If our electrons start
with FADH2 reduced flavin,
we only transport
about six protons.
That's enough to make two ATPs.
If you remember, making ATP
is only one of the things
that we can do with the
power of the proton gradient.
I mentioned earlier
that we can also use
it to generate heat and motion.
Let me talk for a
minute about why one
would want to generate heat.
Newborn babies are
like small balls.
They have a high
surface to volume ratio.
Their high surface
to volume ratio
makes heat loss a very
significant reality,
and, in fact, a problem
for the newborn.
They have, therefore,
specialized mitochondria
in their neck in an
area called brown fat.
The fat is brown because it
is loaded with highly colored
mitochondria.
These mitochondria
have a protein
that enables the protons pumped
into the intermembrane space
to flow back freely into
the mitochondrial matrix
with the generation of heat.
That is, they don't make ATP in
the brown fat, they make heat.
This helps promote thermal
regulation in the baby.
This is also the
mechanism by which
hibernating animals,
such as a bear,
can maintain body
temperature during the winter
when the bear is hibernating.
This process overall
is called uncoupling
of electron transport,
from the process
that we're going to be
looking at next, oxidative
phosphorylation.
Oxidative phosphorylation
is the process by which
we're going to be making ATP.
Uncoupling is also
a process used
by some flowers
that have to come up
through frozen ground
in the springtime.
For example, the skunk
cabbage and the crocus
are very good at uncoupling
electron transport
from oxidative phosphorylation.
They let the protons in
the proton gradient flow
back across the
mitochondrial inner membrane,
and by doing so these
plants are able to generate
heat that will
allow them to grow
at subfreezing temperatures.
In other words, the plant
itself becomes a little heater.
At this point, let me
give you a little bit
of a preview of how we use
this proton gradient in order
to synthesize ATP.
As we have seen, it
took energy in order
to create a gradient in
which there are protons
in the intermembrane space, and
protons are chemical entities,
so we've created a
chemical gradient.
But also, we're putting a
very high positive charge
density in the small,
enclosed intermembrane space.
So we have also created an
electrochemical gradient.
It is the release of those
gradients that empowers
many of our vital processes.
For a final comment please see
panel D. Peter Mitchell figured
out how the energy in that
electrochemical gradient
could be released and
converted into the energy
it takes to make chemical bonds.
Mitchell's conclusions
serve as the basis
of what is called the
chemiosmotic coupling
hypothesis, and we'll be looking
at that in some detail later.